نصل الان الى الازمه الصربيه الكوسوفي حيث
قالت رئيسه كوسوفا فيوزا عثماني انها
منفتحه على اجراء انتخابات بلديه جديده في
المناطق ذات الاغلبيه الصربيه التي تشهد
اضطرابات منذ نحو اسبوعين لكنها لفتت في
مقابلات خاصه مع وكاله روجرز الى انه قبل
اجراء انتخابات جديده تريد كوسوفو ضمانات
من المجتمع الدولي بان لا تتدخل صربيا في
ذلك
واقلت عثماني ان كوسوفو تريد بقاء قوات
الناتو على اراضيها حتى انضمامها الى
الحلف
من جهتها من جهته قلم بوثل الامريكي
لمنطقه غرب البلقان جابرييل اسكوبار ان
روسيا تستغل الازمه بين صربيا وكوسوفو
وتستغل الانقسامات داخل اوروبا لصالح عدم
توسع الاتحاد الاوروبي واضاف خلال مؤتمر
صحفي بلغراد ان واشنطن ملتزمه بمساعده
صربيا وكوسوفو على حل الازمه بما يحقق
مصلحه الطرفين واشار اسكوبار الى ان
الولايات المتحده تامل ان تلتزم كوسوفو
بالمطالب التي يطرحها المبعوث الاوروبي
لخفض التصعيد
معنا من برشتينا مراسله جزيره محمد
المدهون اذا محمد عمليا ما الذي او ما هي
الخطوات التي ستقوم بها
كوسوفو من اجل خفض التصعيد وفقا لما طلب
به المبعوثه الاوروبي
حسن حتى الان لم يعلن عن خطوات عمليه من
قبل رئيس حكومه كوسوفو ويبدو ان هذا
الحديث من قبل رئيسه كوسوفو فيوزا عثماني
هي تحاول ان تقدم له سلما كي ينزل عن
موقفه المتشدد والذي لا يعجب الولايات
المتحده ولا الاتحاد الاوروبي وقد سمعنا
كلاما من المبعوث الامريكي الخاص بغرب
البلقان جابرييل اسكوبار عن عدم تعاون
رئيس حكومه
وعدم تنسيقه مع الحلفاء
والشركاء مع الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبيه على وجه التحديد وهي تحاول ان
تعطي جانبا عمليا تنفيذيا لامكانيه ان
تعاد هذه الانتخابات التي اشار هو ايضا
رئيس حكومه كوسوفو الى انفتاحه على
اعادتها ولكن المطلب الان ان تعاد في اقرب
وقت ممكن وان تسحب كسفه عربات شرطتها من
محيطي هذه البلديات والا يتوجه رؤساء
البلديات المنتخبون اخيرا الى مقر وان
يعملوا من اماكن بديله مطالب واضحه صحيح
ان التوتر في بلديات شمال كوسوفو ولكن خفض
هذا التوتر ونزع فتيل التصعيد موجود هنا
في برشتينا في هذا المبنى خلفي لرئيس
الحكومه الذي ما زال يتصرف وكانه ناشط
سياسي كما يقول بعض المراقبين وليس كرسي
حكومه هناك تشدد في موقفه يريد ان تبدا
جموع المحتجين بالانسحاب المحتجين
العنيفين كما يصفهم قبل ان يسحب عربات
شرطته وهذا امر لا يريد الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده ان يستمر لوقت طويل
وهناك تلويح ببعض العقوبات التي يسميها
الطرفان اجراءات حازمه ولكن هي فعليا
عقوبات بعض المصادر الصحفيه تتحدث عن
الغاء تحرير التاشيره لمواطنين كوسوفو كي
يتنقلوا في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي عن وقف
الدعم المالي من واشنطن وكذلك عن قطع بعض
العلاقات والقنوات قنوات الاتصال
الدبلوماسيه مع حكومه كوسوفو طالميه البين
كورتي رئيس الحكومه متشددا في موقفه هذا
شكرا لك محمد المدهون من برش